every Wednesday or morning round series
looks at medical issues that could
affect you and solutions for a better
health endometriosis is a reproductive
disease that affects women about half of
patients with it have fertility problems
and it's cause is still uncertain today
celebrities including Lena Dunham Susan
Sarandon
Padma Lakshmi and Whoopi Goldberg are
now helping raise awareness and research
money or dr. Tara nurullah is here with
more on the story
Tara good morning to you how many women
are affected good morning Gail well
according to the endometriosis
Foundation of America the disease
impacts an estimated 10 percent of women
in their reproductive years because the
disease has diverse symptoms and since
there's no blood or imaging test women
are often shuttled from Doctor to doctor
before they get the right diagnosis
beautiful
Georgie Kovacs Barden's path to
motherhood spanned three years and
twelve fertility treatments before she
gave birth to her three-year-old son
Connor at age 40 after seeing 10 doctors
she finally learned why she had
difficulty getting pregnant when you
were told you had endometriosis what was
your reaction thank you for giving me a
diagnosis in my gut I knew I said once
we figure out the underlying cause I
will get pregnant for many women like
Georgie the only sign of endometriosis
is infertility but most patients have
severe pain during their menstrual cycle
endometriosis occurs when tissue similar
to the lining of the uterus appears
outside the uterine cavity scattered
throughout the pelvis and abdomen
researchers are still working to
understand how this happens the lag time
between onset of symptoms and diagnosis
is usually anywhere from 8 to 10 years
dr. Arnold Advan Kela performs the
minimally invasive surgery required to
diagnose and remove the tell-tale
lesions that interfere with getting
pregnant and disrupt women's lives
women are plagued with chronic pain
symptoms which can be quite disruptive
to quality of life and also affects
women at a time in their life when there
trying to have a family trying to have
their first baby a baby is still a
question mark for Stephanie Morris who
was diagnosed 11 years ago I can go from
feeling perfectly fine in one moment to
doubled over in pain screaming crying I
remember thinking on my wedding day like
please just let me make it through today
Stephanie now helps educate teenagers
who may be unaware that severe pain
could be more than just monthly cramps
we're told from a very young age to
ignore this part of our body after
struggling with endometriosis for
decades
Columbia University researcher Noemi
al-haddad developed a smartphone app to
track symptoms and gain a better
understanding of the disease was it hard
to sleep to get out of bed data
collected from 9,000 women so far shows
that women can have pain outside the
time of their menstrual period and
symptoms can include things like low
back pain ringing in the ears bowel and
bladder problems and even chest pain we
talked about technology and apps as ways
to give patients control and this sounds
like a very important way to give women
way to have control absolutely and we
can't help them yet wheeze relief but at
least we can give them as a validation
and the better communication tools how
do you think your life would have
changed if one of those first
specialists had said to you you might
have endometriosis I would be in a
better place financially I would have
more children I mean I still I'm
struggling with letting go of not having
more children
removing lesions with laparoscopic
surgery is considered the best treatment
option however many men women may also
be treated with hormones oral
contraceptives painkillers and even
hysterectomy listen Tara I know regular
cramp pain can just be kind of
excruciating how do you know the
difference between regular cramps that
are can be painful in Indo mystery osis
that's a great question we actually
asked dr. anything cool of that and
essentially he said if the pain and the
cramps gets progressively worse over
time and it really can't be relieved
with things like NSAID
nonsteroidal antiinflammatory also who
have some of those other systemic
symptoms like chronic fatigue bowel or
bladder problems pain with intercourse
all of that should paint a picture that
really makes you say I need to talk to
my doctor and ask do I have
endometriosis and it's important
everybody said to start this
conversation early with teenagers in
schools so that they don't go fifteen
years before they're diagnosed you can
feel the relief of the women saying I
just wanted somebody yeah what a relief
that is good to see you thank this
important conversation we'll continue on
our CBS s morning Facebook page Tara
we'll be there to answer your questions
about endometriosis during the break